but then the other thing
that is
scary about social media is um
the is conte social contagion of mental
disorders
so
we know
uh we're aware now that
certain proportion of young girls
who are identifying as gender dysphoric
and
trying uh attempting to become
transgender
we're aware now that
there is such a thing as
rapid onset gender dysphoria okay so
there's a book called discovery of the
unconscious which is a great book
henry ellenberger it's it's i was given
that book by
a
psychiatrist at
the douglas hospital who was my
supervisor and french guy maurice
doncice a very distinguished psych
psychiatrist and he said
this is the psychoanalytic bible
discovery of the unconscious and the
first it's about
that thick and it covers jung freud
adler it's great book and but the first
300 pages is a history of
pre-psychoanalytic thought and part of
that is a historical survey of contagion
right and so there so the multiple
personality disorder for example has
cycled through about 300 years
and there there there are there are
people who are temperamentally
susceptible to such contagion they're
likely the same people who are
relatively easily hypnotizable
yeah it's likely associated with high
openness by the way right okay and you
and you could also imagine that if
you're high in openness it's harder for
you to catalyze and specify an identity
and you're more diverse in your inner
life
maybe even your emotional life and so
right and then
there's confusion here too that we
should talk about as psychologists so
sex and gender you know and i've been
accused of just
saying this that those are identical but
i know they're not
because
there is a lot of personality
variability on top of biological sex and
it isn't
like
it isn't a particularly rare woman
who has essentially the same temperament
as the average man sure my suspicions
are it's probably about one woman in 10.
now it would depend on exactly how you
made the cut offs you know but i don't
if it's not 10 maybe it's 5 i don't care
it's somewhere in that range and the
same can be said for men and so it's
perfectly possible for a boy to have a
temperament that's more like a girl but
that does not mean that he's in the
wrong body
that's the raw like that's a pretty
radical solution for a problem that's
essentially a consequence of normal
temperamental variability and so there
is some utility in separating out gender
from sex if you think of gender as
personality which i think is the
appropriate way to think about it
scientifically but
i knew back when the
when i got entangled in my first
political conflict i thought
all this mucking about with gender
categories is going to confuse and hurt
way more people that it's going to help
and part of this is this
problem of contagion of confusion yes so
all adolescents really need that that's
really what they need is more confusion
about
sex and gender when they're 13.
that's just perfect
yeah it's freedom yes like yeah freedom
yeah right yeah
and it wouldn't be it wouldn't be an
issue i mean there's nothing androgyny
has been around for
hundreds thousands of years i mean
there's there's ancient
sculptures of androgynous figures i mean
ancient cultures understood androgyny
and
there's plenty of historical precedent
for the idea that androgynous
personality is actually more of an ideal
there's lots of speculation in christian
mysticism about the androgyny of christ
yeah that's right and you know i
i'm not
i when i was a teenager i used to look
up to androgynous um
celebrities like well david bowie was a
little bit before my time but he was
androgynous i used to
and he was like yeah i mean it wasn't it
was an ideal to emulate
and to be its tomboy was
considered cool but you would never
consider
medical
intervention you would never consider
hormone treatment or
uh modifying your body
how about attempting to make a penis out
of the musculature in your arm
you know penises are actually quite
complex it's not that easy to take your
arm and turn it into one
and certainly not without a tremendous
amount of cost and trouble and then well
and then and then
let's just imagine that you were wrong
and confused just for a moment
you know and the in that the contrary
argument is well you better deal with
this early it's like yeah you really
know that do you you're so bloody sure
about that are you
well they can the the emotional
blackmail that activists have used uh
has been you know this argument that if
kids don't get this early intervention
then they're at higher risk of suicide
well we have absolutely no idea
whether
um
you know we don't you know
suicidal
suicidal ideation or
distress is not easily disentangled from
confusion around your identity it's not
clear that it's simply transphobia or
being trapped no no it's clear that it's
no it's clear that it's simply not it's
not simple first of all as you just
pointed out it's actually unbelievably
complicated
so what do you
difficult things yep yeah well there's a
there's a paper that's been recently um
published by lisa littman who
did the original exploratory research on
rapid onset gender dysphoria and she's
gone and interviewed 100 d transitioners
she's a lot of i think she just talked
to barry weiss about that okay yeah well
her paper well she interviewed dear
transitioners so people who have
transitioned gender
and who now regret it
and
there's a couple of patterns that stand
out one one
uh pattern that stands out is that often
people felt the need to transition after
some trauma had happened to them so they
experienced the trauma
and then another pattern that stands out
is that
these individuals were sort of sold
trans gender transition as a solution to
all of their problems yeah yeah i i
think i read the paper i think that one
of the most common claims of the d
transitioners was that they were
tremendously ill-informed about the full
consequences of their actions by the
relevant medical professionals and and
then we could also say it's certainly
possible that the relevant medical
professionals are too terrified to fully
inform them
well it's their job i mean yeah i know
i'm not it's not an excuse but but it is
but it but but it's it's still worth
noting because you can understand i know
what happened in toronto to the world's
lead researcher on transsexual
transition in children i mean his life
was torn into shreds and he's an
apolitical guy he's just a researcher
and he's a good one as well yeah and so
the the this fear
you know you you can say well
you're a professional it's your duty to
stand up regardless of the fear but
but
when there's that much pressure even
people who stand up are going to be
inclined to speak a lot less than they
might otherwise yeah
i had i've had a press council complaint
made against me before an article i
wrote for the australian on transgender
issues
and it wasn't upheld
but
anytime a journalist in australia wants
to write about
issues particularly to do with medical
intervention
and gender dysphoric kids
they are subject to
complaints press counsel complaints well
and if you're if you're an md or a
psychologist
if someone takes a complaint against you
to your college especially if that
college has been increasingly dominated
by activists you are so screwed
yeah like i i had one client just cause
me just an
unbelievable amount of misery
and well because you can hijack the
whole bureaucracy as a weapon
yeah and so yeah yeah and that's what
these activists do and they're very good
at it and they you know they only need
to have a couple of successes under
their belt and they have a whole system
for attacking people well we have human
rights commissions in canada which are a
quasi-judicial
entity with with increasing power and
that's a perfect weapon for any activist
who's motivated to use it
and that whoever the target of the human
rights commission is you can kiss five
years of their life goodbye and there's
a high probability that they're going to
be found guilty regardless of what they
did
it's really it's it's truly appalling
especially given that it's happening
under the ages hypothetically of human
rights
and and the ability to give informed
consent
and this this is just one this is an
example of how fanatics
hijack
institutions which you would
have previously thought were fairly
centrist and moderate so it's you know
this the transgender activism issue is
is a perfect example because it's a tiny
like transgender activists are a
minority of transgender people
who are a tiny minority anyway so it's
just like the the smallest number of
people creating
an extreme amount of havoc
uh
and it's it's a perfect example of how
this how a tiny intolerant minority
can
uh
basically
dominate others
using all of the all of the new tools
that we have today social media
uh
you know bureaucratic complaints
mobbing that type of thing